hey what's going on a spill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
Anna Jess check-in how was your week
going is it going well I am in gloomy
rainy Vancouver British Columbia home of
the BC Lions the Vancouver Canucks and
the [ __ ] Westminster Dog Show that
unless some place out here Westminster
and I learned today that they do have a
big dog show up here but I don't think
they are one in the same I can't
remember if Westminster takes place in
Beverly Hills or in New York City but
all I know is that you have to be a
particular level white person to be
invited I learned that because I thought
I was white enough you know and they
were like oh no you are not and my dream
of attending it I just think it's funny
I like dogs and then it's just funny
when they get them or like you know all
shampooed up and then prancing around
you know and I don't know there's always
like that thought of what if the owner
false just adds to the tension you know
anyways I'm up here in Vancouver I'm
having a great time this past weekend I
went to a wedding awesome wedding
tremendous wedding to people that should
be getting married they totally had the
connection is there anything worse
unless you're just really into shied and
Freud when you go to a wedding and you
just see two people and you're like this
[ __ ] thing is not gonna last the
weekend I've been to two of those and
one of them the marriage lasted two
years maybe and then the other one as
far as I know they're still together the
first weird wedding that I went to I
think the bride was having second
thoughts because the groom was standing
up there forever
and then she just sort of walked down
the hall walked on down all right walk
down the aisle with their dad and did
not have that look that you know
somebody usually has on their wedding
day and then when she went up to the
altar the whole time they were doing the
vows she was laughing uncontrollably
which you know sometimes it's just a
form of nervousness but uh they didn't
even kiss and as they walked out they
went ahead and kissed but far as I know
they're still together and then another
one was someone I was in business with
when I first got in to New York City and
I went to this person's wedding and I
remember we went out there and the
mother-in-law we got there like it was
traffic when we got there right before
the wedding was gonna start it was in
the backyard of these rich people's
estate right this guy married into money
and he wasn't rich so I think they
didn't like him so she was we pulled up
she was outside walking the dog dressed
the way you would walk a dog like she
wasn't really even ready it was like
sort of this nonverbal protest of what
was going on in there and that seemed
weird I was like wow you know the
in-laws usually never like the [ __ ]
person that daughter's marrying they
never think that he's good enough right
so it didn't really you know wasn't much
of a red flag but then I just remembered
when the groom apps to where they got
married he went to give a toast as to
why he loved his wife and it was [ __ ]
brutal
he was like she because she gave some
big toast to him and so then he goes
okay and did to you my lovely wife you
you you you make me laugh
where the background like light of your
life reason you get up in the morning
like trying to help him out it was one
of those things where everyone was
smiling like this is going to be great
and then it just became like everybody
just sort of looking down going dude
wrap it up wrap it up wrap it up and
that one lasted like two years and it
was such a [ __ ] up marriage I remember
him telling me that they just had this
big fight and they were both kind of
exhausted and one of them was just kind
of like what are we doing and the other
one who was just like yeah do you like
not want to do this anymore
and the other one was like no and then
the other one was like really because I
don't either and then they started
laughing like a bad [ __ ] movie and
they had a really amicable divorce and I
think he was cool he didn't try to take
any of her [ __ ] money and they just
went their separate ways I haven't said
that this wedding that I went to I
always have that in the back of my head
because as much as I like to do stand-up
I don't literally like to be living in a
bit when I'm at a wedding you know I
don't know I just saw him interacting
right before the wedding and you know
it's super stressful if you've ever
gotten married and they just seemed
chill and relaxed so I was like oh good
good but was funny about this wedding
was there was also another bald ginger
at the wedding
with a red beard like my doppelganger
and I went there and I had a drink and
then I had another drink and then I was
just like yeah you know that's good I'm
gonna stop there and I started drinking
water now on the other hand the other
guy was acting like me last year well
before I took four months off of
drinking and this [ __ ] guy got
[ __ ] loaded right so I saw he was
kind of swaying in the breeze and I'm
like uh you know been there I'm not
gonna judge he's having a good time
whatever right so the [ __ ] guy next
thing I know I'm looking outside and
this guy like this wedding was so
perfect was in this really cool
restaurant and slash bar
and so up front was the bar and they had
the ceiling to floor windows and the
evil version of me at some point
staggered outside and I just felt
everybody looking and they looked and he
just [ __ ] puked in the street in
front of like a third of the wedding
was up at the bar like a giant puddle of
[ __ ] puke so all his friends rush
outside and that [ __ ] suits to help
him out so he brought a chair up they
sit the guy down and I'm not laughing at
the guy I'm just laughing because I've
been there I mean not in a [ __ ] not
having a whole wedding that I was just
that looking at me but you know we've
all had our moments I remember one time
I was somewhere down the Cape [ __ ]
Cape Cod Joe best [ __ ] potato chips I
somehow passed out on a bluff that was
headed down towards the ocean I was just
like in the middle of the day and I
forget where my buddy was he was the one
driving he was someone was somewhere
else they came out of some ham with the
car and we would just passed out unlike
the [ __ ] this it was a bluff right I
just like saying that word I've never
used it properly and all of a sudden I
was laying there and the Sun felt good
and everything I was passed out and like
it felt like a day later all of a sudden
I just hear and out there that is where
the Nina the Pinta and the Pinta and the
Santa Maria came in back in 14 [ __ ]
blah blah blah blah blah and then I
heard this little kids voice go mommy
why is that guy sleeping there and there
was like some sort of [ __ ] tour going
on and I vaguely remember changing a
tire and I didn't put the jack
underneath the frame and it went like
right through the floor boy
so there you go all right I'm not
judging this guy but it was funny as
[ __ ] hell so this [ __ ] guy
[ __ ] just you know Great Lakes yak
you know puke all over the street so
somebody brings a chair out and they sit
him down and he's sitting there hanging
his head like you know Jordan was
sitting when he had the flu and they put
the towel over his head he was sitting
like that - the towel over his head so
then they start calling like an uber or
lyft and these cars keep pulling up and
they pull up to this bald dude with the
red beard sitting with his head hanging
down in a giant puddle of puke and
everybody would just pull up and be like
[ __ ] guys not getting my car they
would drive away and it just became this
thing like dude you gotta move down the
street you gotta get him away from the
puke and anyway somebody finally came
along it took him home but uh he was
definitely the highlight of the evening
so I wanna I don't know who that guy was
but I want to thank him for the the free
entertainment so anyways let's get back
on track here I'm up here in our
Vancouver and as I mentioned before I
don't mentioned I was talking to a
number of people up here that listen to
this podcast that fly helicopters and
one of them had access to the Kabri g2 I
hope I'm saying that right Cabrio is a
kibrit I think it's Kabri g2 which is
basically like the Robinson r22 that I
fly at but it has you know any safety
issues that the Robinson may or may not
have you know that it does have I'm just
not trying to [ __ ] on it because I fly
it all the time and I do like that
helicopter these people took it to the
next level it's like the next iPhone
except it didn't try to like you know
capture your [ __ ] space it was new
and improved so I wanted to try this
thing out and these people had access to
it so I was going to rent a car today
and drive about an hour outside of
Vancouver but then I got a text from the
guy I was gonna fly was today there's a
guy here he's a big fan of yours he's
got a [ __ ] he's got a 66 he'll pick
you up right at the heliport downtown I
was like [ __ ] it let's do it so I show
up this dude named
Chris I want to thank him great guy pick
me up blew me all the way out there and
I was telling him he goes so how did you
get into wanting to fly the cab Ricci -
and I was like well you know I read all
about you know the low G's you know
situations the mass bumping I got a
little freaked out
Vietnam helicopter pilots I just kind of
feel like it's a bit of a safety issue
and they just sort of taught pilots how
to fly out of it rather than fix it but
what the [ __ ] do I know I only have 160
hours right but that was just my gut
feeling
so I want to check this thing out see
what the deal is with this thing so we
land at the airport and as we land one
of those cavalry G twos is coming in and
I immediately loved it I love the shape
of it and when it landed seeing this
little two-seater with the fully
articulated main rotor system was like I
mean that's that's been the dream you
know because what the r22 you got a lead
with your collective with those things
you could just push the stick forward
which it's still whenever I fly
something like that when the guy just
goes okay knows it forward I always have
to make the joke that you know I usually
don't hear that you know flying around
so anyways the thing lands and as it
lands I see this guy getting out who
looks just like the dude that I saw in
the YouTube video I was like that the
guy who uploaded the video that did the
whole the whole thing from nose to tail
review of it he goes yeah that's him and
it was so surreal because I didn't know
I was gonna meet this guy it was like
literally the guy that was the reason
that I wanted to fly it I end up not
only going to his place I end up getting
to fly with them
it's b/c helicopters and the guy's name
is Misha Gelb and he was incredible
pilot he did an auto rotation at the end
that was just was unreal for those of
you who fly Robinson's there's no watch
and your rpms going too high too low
it's just you just put the collective
down and steer it and he landed this
thing like like like a [ __ ] Daisy it
was incredible and so anyways he he was
filming the entire time that we were
flying and I was flying horribly
I could barely I could even hold a hover
in the thing because the main road had
turned the exact opposite weight as much
as I told myself ignore your muscle
memory just fell you know correct
whichever way the nose is going and it
was also super sensitive it felt like
the sports suspension on a car like a
sports car you know where it was so
hypersensitive that I just kept over
correcting and then it was it took me
back to when I had like under ten hours
flying and was just the first time
trying to hold a hover but uh of course
by the end I got way better than where I
was at but by then his GoPro had ran out
so you can guys that can have a fun time
laughter to me flying this thing like a
[ __ ] salmon going up see upstream it
was pretty bad in the beginning but uh I
really really loved it I got to fly you
know I mean it was definitely a cloudy
day and everything but I thought it was
kind of cool that it was raining out and
all that just to fly in something
different and got to go all along the
the whole skyline of Vancouver all the
way up to where all these rich people
live and [ __ ] and then we flew back and
on the way back we flew up this riverbed
which I hope he keeps that footage
that's one of the coolest things I ever
did I felt like I was on like the
Discovery Channel like I should have
been chasing a bunch of gazelles or
something for watching hippos you know
fighting alligators or something out on
the Serengeti it was amazing and we
ended up landing off the airport up
there we landed off Airport and just
some farmers yard and that's when I was
just like I had it the thing was all
over the place when I was flying but
anyways I just want to thank everybody
at BC helicopters I had such a great
time and I will definitely be back and
for those of you who do fly if you get a
chance to check out one of those Kaveri
g2 is there pretty [ __ ] amazing and
and that's it then I got two more shows
tonight at the Queen Elizabeth Theatre
here and and then I immediately go back
to go hang with the family because
that's the new me right I fly in the day
the gig and then I do the gig the next
day and then I immediately leave cuz I
got my you know my lovely wife and my
daughter I gotta go I gotta get home too
so but enough I only leave for like two
days I don't have that much guilt
well you feel like an absent absentee
father you know so anyways what time do
we got here just 15 minutes and I should
probably do this read here okay me
undies everybody all right you heard me
talk about me undies and you know that I
am a big believer in their product
they're the perfect balance of
comfortable fit every month they have
new and exciting prints and they arrive
at your door in a fun bag now when I was
a kid that was a term for titties hey
look at the fun bags on that broad so I
guess they arrived at Brian in a fun bag
the undies
uses lady the undies uses lensing micro
mode al modal and no kibrit Kabri and
their underwear
it's sustainably sourced naturally soft
fiber that starts with beech wood trees
the underwear is made out of trees and
ends with the most amazing fabric you've
ever experienced the results have been
downright dreamy well thank God I
wouldn't want to pet my ball bag it's
stamped with the splenic me undies is so
sure you'll love their underwear they
offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee if
you don't love your first pair you get a
full refund that's a no-brainer get 20%
off a pinion pair the most comfortable
undies that you will ever put on [ __ ]
and I get to a sentence to get you 20%
off your first pair free shipping and
100% satisfaction guarantee go to the
undies dot-com / / that's me undies
dot-com
/ / alright let's take a second to talk
about the [ __ ] Oscars congratulations
to everyone who was nominated and
everybody who won but in particular two
people one I don't know if you
attention but two people that won an
Oscar on Monday also do a voice on the
wonderful cartoon fsor family Allison
Janney who did the voice of mrs. plaster
where she won an Oscar for the Tonya
Harding movie and then Sam Rockwell who
does the voice of Frank's nemesis even
though he does he's not even aware that
he's this no misis Vick Reynolds won 4-3
billboards so that's pretty cool you
know I think that upped the ante of our
show the status anyways - I know I'm
throwing that in who does your show who
do you do your show with Oh - Oscar
winners Allison Janney and Sam Rockwell
right Laura Dern Justin Long Dave
Koechner I mean I can go on forever by
the way I'm really loving I don't jinx
it but this season three I know I'm
teasing it early but uh we've been
laughing our asses off in the the Edit
room but I got to tell you yesterday I I
came in landed and I was really tired
because I did a show the night before
did a four-shot show down at the improv
and I had a beer or two after at the end
of the at the end of the show and I
didn't get home to like you know one in
the morning or something like that and
then my daughter my daughter gets up at
like a quarter to 6 6 o'clock it's
hilarious you know you just come
downstairs you can't you know even at
this point like the reason why I drink
so little now is now I don't know what
happened like if I have like like one
beer or two beers like the next day you
know my daughter wakes me up and it's
just like I feel it some waking up just
not like a hungover but just feeling
like less energized and you know she's
talking all this gibberish out there and
I just opened the door and the second I
open the door she just goes hi
I don't know if I told you like hi is
her word for everything hi means hi hi
means I want that or if she wants
attention she does like this frantic
like hi hi hi like if she sees two
people talking and she wants to be it's
really like her being like hey hey hey
little help over here I want to get out
of this [ __ ] chair so anyway so I
didn't get a lot of sleep and then I had
to go to the airport and then I flew up
and whenever you fly in the plane this
it's always like everybody wants to
sleep except for that one person who has
the window open and then I can't fall
asleep so I get to the hotel and I'm
like I I'm just gonna lay down here for
like a half an hour and I had South Park
on speaking of you know animated shows
just total next-level absolutely [ __ ]
hilarious and I was watching this
episode what Cartman had stolen a bunch
of boats and I said I fell asleep and I
woke up a little later and held my eyes
and South Park was still on I didn't
realize that they had a marathon going
on like they did like three or four
episodes in a row long story short my
pickup for the 7 o'clock show is at 6:20
and I am asleep and I was sudden the
phone rings super loud in my room and I
opened my eyes and it's pitch black in
the room and I was like oh [ __ ] and I
was trying to find my way out and I
couldn't I literally open the door that
went into a closet and then virzi called
me and I saw it was 6:30 and I literally
just threw my clothes on didn't even
iron my shirt got to the venue sipped a
little stroke Coty and went out on stage
had a great set though but I was like
really
it was weird I was like I wasn't tired
because I slept for like three hours so
I felt refreshed but I also felt like I
just woke up so I don't know if the
first 10 minutes the show felt like an
out-of-body experience but I've never
slept like like that close up until like
almost
missing a show or something like that
but uh fortunately you know it went well
I don't that kind of went nowhere you
know why I almost missed my show but I
didn't and then the show went well like
did I really need to [ __ ] tell you
all of that was there a reason for that
I apologize that this recording sucks I
bought an external mic for my iPhone
that Kevin Shea the hilarious Kevin Shea
who came on my show that's right came on
the Monday morning podcast promoted his
special and told me all about this mic
go and I love this [ __ ] microphone
I'm have to talk to him about it because
I ordered it up the Internet there the
interweb and it was only 20 bucks I'm
like how the [ __ ] is a microphone that
only cost $20 gonna be good and guess
what it isn't it [ __ ] sucks so I must
be using it wrong because Kevin Shay's a
smart guy so he's got to teach me how to
use the [ __ ] thing cuz it sounds
worse than if I just hold the phone up
like I am right now if that makes any
sense but anyways I oh my god I have to
tell you this [ __ ] stupid t-shirt
that I saw and there's like some
corporation up here you know selling
clothes one of those what in one of
those [ __ ] clothes a place in on the
mannequins they have all this these jeez
[ __ ] political t-shirts about equal
pay for women and it says like enough is
enough and something about equality and
all that and it's just like I just can't
like these [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like
you were the guys not [ __ ] paying
people like why am I getting a [ __ ]
like my voice cracking it what the [ __ ]
are you how do you get off selling those
[ __ ] shirts I don't understand why
these feminist groups don't go in there
and be like ok you're selling enough is
enough t-shirts
why you somewhat let's look into your
[ __ ] history of paying people that's
like this new this new [ __ ] thing
what it is it's not a new thing this is
what people always do when if movement
happens and they get freaked out by it
what they eventually do is they join it
and once they join it they have like a
level of control or they could just act
like they [ __ ] agree with it so then
like you don't nobody's looking at you
like you're a problem you basically
you just cut sort of send it down the
line like no problem here look we have
enough is enough
t-shirts I actually have enough as
enough thing
enough is enough as far as just going
after what guys do to women how about we
balanced it out you know and some on all
this [ __ ] that [ __ ] women do to guys
you know uh that'll never happen oh you
can't do that if you do that then you're
a [ __ ] sexist we're gonna fix the
male-female dynamic by only examining
the behavior of men because the ladies
are perfect I would love to know what
sweatshop makes those enough is enough
t-shirts what a [ __ ] is Michael Moore
been lately well actually it's a t-shirt
sold here in Canada and God knows he
blows everybody north of [ __ ] in
Minnesota he just thinks that you know
like everything Canada can do no wrong
despite the fact it's one of the most
overtly racist places I've ever been to
the entire country you know what I mean
but all you got to do is put on a silly
hat and take some syrup out of a [ __ ]
tree and then Michael Moore is just like
oh my god these people are amazing Oh
bill why would you do that
why why why would you have such a nice
friendly podcast and then you know just
have to pick on and you know punch up
bill
why can't you punch up so what I've
learned here about Vancouver other than
its beautiful and that they like they
like buildings that look like the
buildings that Godzilla steps on notice
that there's a lot of a lot of money
from China here you know I don't know
what the [ __ ] happened in China but some
sort of crackdown happened and there was
a bunch of rich Chinese people where
they were just like oh [ __ ] we got to
get our money out of this country and
they started buying up property along
Sunset Strip a bunch of places in the
United States and evidently here in
Vancouver and I got a I got a commend
[Music]
Chinese people with money those people
know where to [ __ ] buy you know
although I think Vancouver's smarter
than LA with the global warming with all
the you know slush
and up here with all the water you know
lakes and everything it's absolutely
beautiful
I don't know there must be incredible to
leave China and come to Vancouver we can
actually have space but then it'd be
weird cuz you'd miss you know you'd miss
your country right but uh I know just
haven't been over there how crowded it
is and how dirty the air is it's got to
be [ __ ] incredible because I think
it's incredible just coming up from LA
you know and it was like a [ __ ]
zillion people all these people coming
out here lugging their goddamn skis
skiing is [ __ ] incredible but I gotta
tell you you literally have to be like
your own roadie you know and there was
all these people like you know you got
to go snowboard man you can just have
that like a backpack just throw it over
your [ __ ] shoulders right it seems to
be like I was just sort of analyzing
like skiing scares the [ __ ] out of me
because it's like every year some
[ __ ] guy around my age usually people
my age you know late 40s early 50s and
they just come down a trail and they hit
a tree and then that's just [ __ ] it
but the last time I skied I was in Utah
and doing a gig out there and the
comedian I was working with wanted to go
skiing so we went I [ __ ] dislocated my
thumb and like nine times I thought I
was going to blow out my knees and I
vowed I would never go again and if I
did I would go snowboarding I would much
rather deal with a broken tailbone or a
[ __ ] up wrist than a blown out knee
you know in my if my advanced stage so
anyways I am gonna go over to the venue
right now cuz they allegedly they got a
drum kit backstage at that place so I
think I'm gonna go over there and go jam
man and some [ __ ] tunes good clean
fun and then I'm gonna do my two shows
and listen to this I come home I go to
bed and then I have to get up at four in
the morning because I have to call I got
a call back east because I got a big
show coming up in Boston and I got a
cell
bunch of tickets oh and they want me to
come on the radio live and so that's
gonna be my day so I'm gonna wake up at
4:00 in the [ __ ] morning do that [ __ ]
and then go to the goddamn Airport and
then come home and my daughter's gonna
be like [ __ ] bouncing off the walls
ready to play but you know what it's
gonna be great you know what's cool is
she we have this doorway to our house
where it's got like you know you got the
door and then along both sides it has
like these those old-fashioned like
little windows that go from the top all
the way down to the bottom so it's the
greatest thing ever when you come home
because she's looking through smiling at
you but it's the worst when you leave
you know because she has like the
saddest look on her face because now she
actually understands when you're leaving
so and I got a feeling it's only going
to get worse I just want to get to the
point where it's like I'm never want to
be the point where I leave so much that
it's no big deal you know like I'm a
long time ago Danny Gans the late Danny
Gans told the story of well how he ended
up in Vegas is his kid drew a family
portrait and it was the mother and all
the kids and then he goes oh that's
great where's daddy and then she pointed
and she had drawn an airplane and he was
on the airplane in a way I was like oh
[ __ ] but what am I gonna do this is what
the [ __ ] I do for a living we also
announced some dates over two dates one
in Dublin and one in London and I know I
got some [ __ ] from people why don't you
come here why don't you come there I'm
gonna do more of an extensive tour
through Europe at some point I just have
to figure out I got to balance my new
life here with the wife and kid but I
definitely want to get to places that
had been before in places that I have
never been I just have to figure out how
to do it but when I go to that Dublin in
London gig that's that's the week of my
50th birthday so I'm doing Dublin first
and then I'm doing Royal Albert Hall
which is insane then I'm gonna be there
I can't believe it and that's going to
be for my 50th birthday
and then I'm taking a week off and
hanging with you know my wife and kid
and everything and that's how I'm gonna
celebrate turning 50 man what the [ __ ]
so I don't know most a lot of my friends
didn't make it this far so I'm not gonna
[ __ ] about it but if it's a big number
okay hey rough one all right all right
well that's the podcast thank you guys
for listening and thank you everybody up
here in Vancouver they came up to the
show last night and I'm coming tonight
amazing crowd last night I think it's
gonna be more of the same tonight have a
great weekend yet [ __ ] and I'll talk to
you on Monday
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up everybody it's bill burr
and it is the Monday morning podcast for
Monday March the 8th 2010 oh my god
could you believe the Oscars last night
I can't believe that Kelly Wigan [ __ ]
and faith didn't get Beth supporting
[ __ ] for let's make a [ __ ] Afghan in
the 1800s do you know I'm actually still
in San Jose right now and I was supposed
to have a show tonight I'm actually
recording this on Sunday I was supposed
to have a show tonight but it got
cancelled because everybody evidently is
watching the [ __ ] Oscars I can
understand if you're a broad and you
want to watch that [ __ ] I get it that's
like your Super Bowl will you get to sit
there and watch the different dresses
and which couple is with which couple
and who just broke up and are they there
with their new boyfriend or girlfriend
and oh my god did they ignore each other
on the red carpet and look at some
[ __ ] [ __ ] yank back face as she
talks about their shoes I get that but
where the [ __ ] were the men in San Jose
whoever had the enough [ __ ] balls
left in their relationship to be like
you know what I'm not going to your
stupid [ __ ] Oscar party okay because
I don't want to listen to [ __ ] 98
different reads of oh my god you know oh
my god why is he wearing that Jess oh my
god she looked so beautiful oh my god
that was like the best speech ever huh
is that what you did he's sitting in
your cubicle right now as a man is that
what you did last night because if he
did he should be hanging your [ __ ]
head huh
what happened let's go down memory lane
okay
go all the way back to high school when
you still had a set of balls between
your [ __ ] legs remember that they
were brand new and they were ready to go
I got a question for you where the [ __ ]
did they go because you different you
definitely didn't have them men of San
Jose because you weren't in my [ __ ]
show last night to the point it had to
be canceled granted I'm not gonna lie
about a [ __ ] month and a half ago a
married couple came out of a bar got
into it the bouncer a cop showed up and
he [ __ ] tased the dudes why
and shot the guy in the abdomen and the
dude damn near bled out right in front
of the improv here look it up online
they got the picture
you know after there's a shooting they
clean up the mess there's always the
[ __ ] old ketchup stains on the
sidewalk and a couple of articles of
clothing and then it's [ __ ] hilarious
and then right right next to it they had
the marquee and it still said Eddie
Griffin who's funny so yeah I guess that
isn't good for [ __ ] business but um I
gotta tell you man I had a great time
coming up here and I've avoided coming
to San Jose because I was worried that
basically what happened Sunday night I
thought was gonna happen all week
because I don't know what is about
California I just feel like if you're
not a you're not a [ __ ] Latino comic
you know I just saw our super famous
you're not gonna sell any tickets out
here because you know people put that in
my head
but no a lot of people came out on a
Saturday night they actually had a
balcony that was the thing about on
Friday nobody showed up right so there I
am I'm standing in this huge [ __ ]
theater and the entire upper deck is
empty I felt like I was performing at a
[ __ ] Royals game you know I felt like
I should have been like singing the
national anthem or something like that
and then yelling at my manager wondering
what happened to my [ __ ] music career
that I couldn't at least sing it like an
Angels game well those [ __ ] idiots
got to come out there with their day if
they're dead goddamn noisemakers how
lame of you is fans that the ownership
is basically saying you know what you
guys have such a lack of passion we need
them we need to invent something to make
it sound like you guys care way more
than you really do here here's a couple
inflatable [ __ ] plastic balloons just
slam them together we'll even get a
monkey we'll have a crazy monkey out
there [ __ ] angels um anyways what am
I doing here what the [ __ ] am I talking
about
I actually I had a great weekend and
believe it all you wouldn't know it from
my voice and I found a great sushi place
out here check out smile susi sushi if
you get a chance to
I don't know where the [ __ ] it is but
you have the internet right
look at me I'm [ __ ] walking around
right now I'm looking out the window
they got a museum across the street and
they have a Star Trek exhibition and you
should have seen these [ __ ] nerds you
should have seen these [ __ ] nerds
just just just standing outside like
waiting for a museum to open that's when
you know you're a [ __ ] nerd okay
everybody's gone to museum but who the
[ __ ] has ever stood outside a museum
with your face pressed against the glass
waiting for the [ __ ] thing to open up
you know Jesus cry mean III see back in
the day your what you waiting for
[ __ ] concert tickets you know what I
mean back in the day when they used to
have like actually have record stores
and the artists would come through and
you'd be standing outside strawberries
records and tapes you know waiting to
have your cassettes signed by Bryan
Adams what did I pick Bryan Adams I'll
tell you why because I'm staying at a
very nice hotel as I've made it to that
level in this business alright I am on
the 14th floor the penthouse [ __ ]
level although I just have a suite I
haven't got to that level yet and I'm
looking out the barren [ __ ] landscape
here as far as people go anyways but
anyways I went down to the [ __ ] place
to have breakfast and the second I
walked in right all I see is is this
cloth napkins and leather-bound menus so
right there you know it's gonna be like
58 bucks for an omelet so all I want to
do is stop and turn around and get the
[ __ ] out of the place but do I of course
I don't you know why because there's so
few people in there that everybody
looked at me when I came in and it
reminded me of this time when I went to
this titty bar in Troy New York I
believe it was Troy New York was called
the cloud night any perverts out there
you know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
it's not really is it's sort of a strip
club sort of a guy's house I would have
to describe it as I just remember there
was an upstairs when he came walking and
that literally looked like some old lady
should have came down in our house code
and just been like can you can you stop
all this tripping
I'm trying to sleep and then some sort
double-wide trailer that sold videos
that was attached to the other side of
it but anyways long story short I went
in there with two other people who will
remain nameless because I don't name
names in the [ __ ] podcast because I'm
old school I can't even [ __ ] remember
who they are anyways I've talked to my
cellphone so [ __ ] much so anyways I
walk into the goddamn place we all walk
in and the second we walk in all we want
to do is turn around and walk out but
there's so few [ __ ] people in there
everybody's looking at us the dancer the
[ __ ] deejay the [ __ ] porky guy who
runs the goddamn place and the two
[ __ ] immigrant truckers who were
sitting in there I believe they were
Yugoslavia I can't remember what see you
know you just [ __ ] go in and sit down
so I went in and I sat down at this
[ __ ] breakfast place I'm back to the
breakfast place alright try to keep up
I'm playing these [ __ ] brain games on
the internet who write my [ __ ] brain
is sharp it's coming back god I'm lonely
anyways so I sit down at this [ __ ]
breakfast place and there's this
medium-sized woman who suffers from
vocal fry' and for those of you who
didn't major in communications and
didn't have to take a career speech
class vocal fry is basically a way of
speaking where you're not you're not
forcing enough air through your vocal
cords so you thought you talk like that
they hurt you ever heard people's like
that oh my god I was up at Amy's house
the other day and I just felt like she
was giving me this vibe or you have the
other people who start off where they
they they they push enough air through
their vocal cords but then towards the
end they taper off today everyone we're
going to be reading about a lady about a
man and it [ __ ] drives you nuts I
never used to bug me until I took a
class on it now I can't stop hearing so
this [ __ ] idiot
is sitting there talking like the
typical like I don't know she sounded
very intelligent but all she was talking
about was like us magazines [ __ ] and
meanwhile I was listening to a
instrumental of a Bryan Adams
over the [ __ ] radio you know when
Brian Anna's first came out he had the
Fonzie leather jacket right and you're
like wow this guy's good he's got some
decent tones you know got my first field
60 remember that I mean he was so young
you thought that that actually rocked
but it wasn't bad for pop and then he
just [ __ ] jumped the shark where he's
just like you know what I can't [ __ ]
do this anymore my face is breaking out
I can't [ __ ] do it anymore I'm just
gonna sell out I'm gonna write a song
for chicks Richard Marx can do it so can
i and then he had that song that song
okay yeah that stupid [ __ ] song they
used to make receptionist's tear up all
across this country when it would come
on in a dental office they had an
instrumental version of that going on as
I ate my [ __ ] scrambled eggs and
listened to this fat [ __ ] talk about
Little House on the Prairie with vocal
fry so that was probably the low point
of the weekend I don't even know what
I'm talking about you know what I did
want to hype i wanted to hype jesus
christ that was only ten minutes there's
no [ __ ] way I'm making this one this
one's gonna be short and sweet everybody
or short and mediocre however you want
to [ __ ] call it let's get the Refresh
pray page let's see how the Bruins and
the Penguins are doing Bruins need to
win this one gotta make sure we make the
playoffs so we can [ __ ] lose in the
first round still one to one after two
periods two friends of mine Billy
Gardell and Randy Bowman are bauman are
at the at the Penguins game right now
Randy Bauman from Jim and Randy show WD
ve in Pittsburgh have a [ __ ] listen
they're sitting there talking [ __ ]
texting me talking [ __ ] you know right
before the game about how the Penguins
were gonna kill the Bruins you know
we're having an off year and lo and
behold you know an hour goes by there's
no [ __ ] talking so I go on the internet
there it is zero zero after the first
[ __ ] period
he's [ __ ] [ __ ] Penguin fans you
know Harry Sinden of the Bruins was
actually debating suing the Pittsburgh
Penguins when
switch to black and gold for stealing
the Bruins colors you know I'm gonna
pause here and let the people in
Pittsburgh exhale and be like the Bruins
have been around since before the
[ __ ] Steelers and the Steelers back
in the day used to basically have yellow
uniforms and that big stupid yellow
helmet that's what they had all right
the only black you had was a couple
little stripes that's all it was back
then when you play the old 23 skidoo the
long I say the long pass when you were
doing that [ __ ] so I don't want to hear
it
and plus you don't I mean who the [ __ ]
takes the exact same colors as another
team in the same league okay you started
off with your gay little baby blue
[ __ ] penguin you know first of all
your penguins why am i talking [ __ ] that
I I'm gonna get hit with the obvious
suppose the last time you guys want a
cup 1982 then shut the [ __ ] up bill fine
I will all right you just keep enjoying
that [ __ ] whiny [ __ ] he's not a
[ __ ] but have you ever seen I haven't
seen anybody whine the way Cindy Crosby
whines since [ __ ] he's like Danny
Ainge on skates pal if Pau Gasol played
[ __ ] hockey and was a good-looking
guy with full ruby red lips from Nova
Scotia
all right so whatever let's hit refresh
again do they at least make the end of
the [ __ ] period here come on Bruins
there we go the end of two one two one
what do you guys say now they have Billy
Gardell [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright what was I trying to say here oh
I know I wanted to hype is of one of the
fans here on the podcast who will also
remain nameless has started a fan page
for the Monday morning podcast okay so
I'm actually going to the next level
with this podcast a lot of times I make
references and you know people you know
don't have time to look them up or maybe
you don't to go all of the internet
trying to figure out what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about this guy has a bunch of
you know has links to some of the
references he you know does all that
photoshop stuff he does all that
computer stuff that I don't know how to
describe
but basically if you'd like to check it
out at the end of the podcast or maybe
follow along you can go to a page called
WWE mm podcast comm www dot the MM
podcast.com no spaces okay
and there you go I'm hyping that for the
week see this is why I don't hype [ __ ]
now I just whatever flow I just [ __ ]
had is out the goddamn window what else
did I do here you know I like about San
Jose is it it is actually a hockey town
like in my hotel they have the NHL
channel and I was sitting there watching
Hockey Night in Canada which is Saturday
night and I what the [ __ ] was I watching
I was watching Toronto versus Ottawa and
I had to go do my show but coming up
they had the LA Kings versus the
Canadians with any luck they [ __ ]
beat him did they beat him you know what
I'm gonna check God knows I got nothing
else to talk about on this [ __ ]
podcast no you know what let's continue
the sports theme just so we can get rid
of all the people who aren't into sports
and are into other things like politics
the [ __ ] is up with that what's the deal
with people who were informed on a
number of weeks ago I actually I ripped
Peyton Manning a new [ __ ] and upon
listening back to it you know I actually
sounded like half of [ __ ] [ __ ] I
will definitely admit that but I still
stand by my opinions and I kept bringing
up a guy by the name of Terry Bradshaw
who has four Super Bowl rings and you
know everybody hit me with dude you only
do for like 20 Frank dealing from
cooking huge well they have a great
article on Terry Bradshaw in Sporting
News magazine this week or this month I
don't really read this magazine but that
kid from Nebraska was on the cover that
damadam I do Moo Kong su damu Kong sue I
don't know he's got a great [ __ ] name
and the Patriots needed defensive tackle
but I know we're not gonna draft high
enough to get that guy but I just wanted
to read about him because I figured
maybe they talk about other defensive
tackles that were available because I
have no life but anyways I open
up and lo and behold there was a great
article about Terry Bradshaw which
basically backs up what the [ __ ] I was
talking about at least in my world it
does and and they mentioned right in the
beginning
it said Bradshaw won his fourth and
final Super Bowl ring with an MVP
performance for the Steelers at the Rose
Bowl among quarterbacks only Joe Montana
has that record and it's quite possibly
none will ever surpass it okay all you
Peyton Manning fans out there do you
think he's gonna get five [ __ ] rings
did will get four I think you could
possibly get three
he's not getting four though alright and
this is coming from [ __ ] Terry
Bradshaw a man who played the game this
is what this is a quote from the article
the only thing that matters in the pros
is winning the Superbowl I've never had
anyone come up to me in my life and say
hey Terry how many yards did you throw
for how many touchdown passes do you
have it's all about rings does that
sound familiar
go listen to the [ __ ] February eighth
podcast maybe Terry listens to my
podcast oh [ __ ] arrogant is that but
then he says he says it's all about
rings but dude the [ __ ] that this guy
took you know I knew in the beginning of
his career that this guy had a rough
time in Pittsburgh and everybody you
know basically treated him like a dumb
redneck and kind of like what they did
with John Rocker
I always fought John Rock I got a bum
deal because I was living in New York
and they were basically calling this guy
a [ __ ] [ __ ] redneck and not so many
words and then he comes out and starts
trash in New York and then typical media
they get to step away like they didn't
incite any of it you know and all the
mets fans get to act like they weren't
[ __ ] yelling [ __ ] at him I used to be
doing a bit about that that uh that of
the the punch line was basically he had
date rapists and wife beaters he
throwing batteries at a bigot that was
basically that was my little [ __ ]
social commentary on that John Rocker
incident let me get back to this [ __ ]
not supporting anything that John Rocker
said but you know what I mean it's like
you know if you're gonna [ __ ] throw
Roxanna and a hornet's nest yeah yeah I
don't know dad I did I almost just say
you're gonna get two stung you don't I
almost just created that was one of
those southern [ __ ] expressions that
I love so much faster and turkey [ __ ]
through a TN horn I'll tell you that boy
that boy [ __ ] rock up you thought a
snake was under it
anybody from down south can just send me
a whole list of those [ __ ] things
have I already done this on the podcast
and I don't remember I absolutely loved
those [ __ ] expressions that Boyd [ __ ]
mud I don't even know what they mean
that boy would [ __ ] a rock if he thought
his snake was under it how does that
make any sense but yet but but what I
love about is even though it doesn't
make sense you you understand what the
person is saying and there's a genius to
that so anyways let me let's read about
Terry Bradshaw's or the early part of
his [ __ ] career basically yeah that
they would they was [ __ ] all over
him well why we have Terry said here he
said you have to understand something my
first five years were not the best I had
[ __ ] thrown in my face I was booed
criticized called stupid and dumb
players talking about was saying this is
the players on his teams we're saying we
win in spite of him he stutters in the
huddle I had so much of that [ __ ] thrown
at me I got bitter about it and my coach
who I thought never defended me in
public Chuck Noll the thing was I was
never his chosen one I had to sit back
and come to grips with all that and was
very painful for me it wasn't a
storybook career so I take a great deal
of pride and being the quarterback of
the team that won all those Super Bowls
yeah and the guy never gets the [ __ ]
respect
do you know before Super Bowl thirteen
Thomas Hollywood Henderson said Terry
Bradshaw couldn't spell cat if he
spotted him the C in the a so they asked
Bradshaw about this and if you watch
football you know he always comes off
like this guy just being all silly and
joking around but he goes well it ticked
me off
the thing that ticked me off was nobody
defended me who came out on my team and
said [ __ ] he calls the place he sets
it up who defended me Chuck Noll didn't
didn't defend me the only guy I know is
said something was Joe Greene
then here I got a deal with this thing
going into the Super Bowl what the hell
am I gonna do I'm smart enough to know
not to get in that argument with
Hollywood Henderson through the media
because it's a distraction I don't have
time for that [ __ ] okay so I can't spell
cat if you spot me the C and the T
that's some good [ __ ] congratulations
then you go out and you kick their asses
how much how's my spelling look now
you're the one who had to go to prison
he took it there Teri's an angry
[ __ ] or whatever I love it I
love it you know something and he never
went back to Pittsburgh I didn't even
notice that [ __ ] when he was done he
just left he doesn't even talk to any of
the players and he said he goes I mean
it's kind of a failure of my personality
I know it's a really interesting article
because if you watch him on whatever the
hell this show is called the NFL pregame
he still plays it up like he's this you
know this is just his country boy but he
isn't he's [ __ ] sharp his attack and
he didn't like the way he was treated in
Pittsburgh and I enjoy that I enjoy that
considering those guys how seriously
they take their team and their [ __ ]
quarterback in game four Super Bowls he
treated him like such [ __ ] you know I
just like I like when teams do that to
their [ __ ] players because it makes
Boston fans look better because God
knows we're a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know kind of like when Montreal
booed Patrick wah out of town I love
bringing this [ __ ] up and then he goes
out to [ __ ] in Colorado and immediately
wins a Stanley Cup and then like four
years later wins another one I love that
now Montreal hasn't been a factor since
[ __ ] in 1993 I love that too it's over
their last dynasty was 1979 they
dominated a 16 League that spilled over
into the expansion six and then
everybody got this [ __ ] together and you
haven't heard anything from those
[ __ ] since and they're still
walking around with that chest puffed
out about some [ __ ] that they did back
in the Three Stooges era you know it's
[ __ ] over 30 years ago it's been 30
years since you guys dominated the
[ __ ] NHL all right so get off your
goddamn high horses all right that ought
to get me a couple of emails okay let's
continue on with the
with the podcast here here's a couple of
videos if you want to watch this one
that I wanted you guys to check out
there's a video if you're Van Halen fan
go on YouTube and check out Van Halen
and it's a song and the cradle will rock
if you just search that a bunch of
videos will come up and click on the
second video down and just look what
David Lee Roth is wearing it's
absolutely [ __ ] hilarious but I'm
telling you as funny as it is there's
gonna be a part of you being like god
dammit I wish I could get away with
wearing something like that can you
imagine the amount of [ __ ] I would get
if I wore something like had the balls
to wear something like that
for those of you who aren't near a
[ __ ] I'll basically describe it who
aren't near a [ __ ] computer right now
maybe you're on a treadmill trying to
work off that burger you ate at Carl's
jr. at 2:00 in the morning no one you
shouldn't have done it woke up this
morning feeling like you had a [ __ ]
anchor in your stomach you know those
[ __ ] sweat it off he's basically
wearing a picture if you if you if you
had a zoot suit made out of spandex and
all you were wearing was the pants so
they basically came up right underneath
you [ __ ] chest right and then do you
remember those remember those [ __ ]
and they're in their purple sparkle -
all right and then that's it you don't
have anything else on other than do you
remember those boots that those [ __ ]
used to wear in Aspen in like the late
70s early 80s where they look like they
skinned a wooly mammoth
he has on white woolly mammoth snow
boots and the greatest thing is the
crowd is just [ __ ] extent cuz it's
early on in their career I don't know if
it's from another country I have no
[ __ ] idea I haven't watched it in a
while but I was just remembering it and
I wanted you guys just check it out
Jesus Christ I told that [ __ ] story
in real time all right here's another
one another YouTube video somebody sent
me it says check out dwarf midgets
killer Muay Thai mu ATH AI this is
basically it's it's very even a very
accurately descript described it it's
one guy is a dwarf and the other guy's a
[ __ ] or a little person that's the new
weight class that they
a little person and they are there
fighting somewhere I'm gonna guess and
maybe the Philippines and it's a Muay
Thai fight and it starts off funny then
you think it's fake because the [ __ ]
keeps hitting the dwarf with the exact
same [ __ ] punch the dwarf keeps
trying to kneel me the [ __ ] in the
chest and the [ __ ] keeps coming with
an overhand right and I will kept
thinking why did [ __ ] is he keep what ik
[ __ ] does he keep throwing the same
punch this must be fake but then I
realized that the boxing gloves on the
[ __ ] actually go beyond his elbow so
he couldn't throw a hook if he wanted to
and then after that it just becomes sad
there's something about the dwarfs face
where he just really looks like he's
getting he's physically in pain the
[ __ ] had you know he still got that
Christmas twinkle in his eye he seems
like he's having a good time he's got a
little bit of swagger in his waddle he's
probably getting some [ __ ] after the
show you know and that's a good question
would you ever let a [ __ ] bang you
women out there I know some guys have
banked a little person but I was just
wondering you know he just laid down on
your stomach and just felt like that
like that wiggling eight-year-old riding
you from behind do you know how long
your hair would have to be so you could
actually pull it in that position why am
I being such an [ __ ] this week I
don't know why alright next next YouTube
video I'll tell you why because I don't
have a [ __ ] show I don't have a show
tonight now I'm waiting to take a
red-eye JetBlue JetBlue back to JFK not
looking forward to going back to New
York this time of year with that [ __ ]
weather I really have not missed the
winner whatsoever that's a big thing
they asked in the East Coast don't you
miss the fourth season what Frankie
Valli in those guys huh do I miss the
four seasons no I don't know I don't I
like it I like being old and being in
the retirement community that is Los
Angeles I like it it's you know what la
is like it's like it's like Florida for
somebody who's still middle-aged
no you go to Florida to die that's the
last place I'll go go out there get me a
gator boat you know that's what I'm
gonna do that's how I'm gonna parachute
out of my life I'm gonna uh you know
I'll probably get a divorce and just say
listen I'm cashing in my chips I can't
do this we had kids alright it's [ __ ]
over they were out of the house what are
gonna do stare at each other for the
rest of [ __ ] time as I sit there
watching you slowly gumming those
waffles that used to be able to tear
through and an English muffin in a
minute and a half now we sit here for
[ __ ] 37 minutes as I watched oh I
don't want to live that life with you
okay we had a great time I give you a
high five but I'm afraid I'm gonna break
your shoulder and then I'll go ahead and
then I'm gonna go down to Florida and
I'm just gonna get one of those [ __ ]
boats with the fan on the back and I'm
gonna give I'm gonna give Everglade
tours is I want to play some Pantera and
some ac/dc I'm gonna have an affected
southern accent and that's it I'm gonna
live off my DVD money even though it
won't exist anymore and I'm a dressed
all in khaki okay let's continue on um
the next youtube video that you can look
at is there's one called public access
TV hosts bombarded with prank calls is
the name of it I don't know if this is
the right video somebody sent this one
to me and I accidentally deleted it so I
just by him describing it I think this
is the one so look it up and it's
basically a guy in public access trying
to talk about gun control and it's such
a low budget that you know it's not
Preet it's it's basically live and he
puts his phone number up there so
somebody calls in realizes is it you
know realizes that it's live and tells
them to go [ __ ] himself
and then the entire audience like a
bunch of goddamn children call in and
all they're saying is just the dirtiest
[ __ ] that they can basically think of
and now the best guys are the ones who
actually start talking about gun control
for a minute so this guy actually feels
like he's having a discussion and right
as the guy starts to engage with them
they tell him to go [ __ ] himself so if
you're an angry prick like me it's a
night it's actually a yeah it's a nice
one so with that
I have been on Lumosity comm for all of
last week trying to get my BPI score to
go up which is I don't know what the
[ __ ] it stands for basically the higher
the number you have the less [ __ ] I
don't know I was gonna say [ __ ] but
I don't like using that word even though
I've already said it five times his
[ __ ] podcast the less dumb you are I
guess are the smarter you are the higher
it is right I got confused in the middle
of it I don't know I'm worried about my
brain right now everybody because it's
feeling fuzzy and I think a lot of it
has to do with talking on my cell phone
too much and I'm trying to cut down on
that like a cigarette smoker and I've
been going to this this website Lumosity
calm and has these these games that
challenge your brain it's it's the
[ __ ] awesome and they got everything
out any any type of any type of stuff
that you could be thinking of I don't
know if I talked about this last week so
I'll kind of blow through it it's
Lumosity l um os ity dot-com somebody
else also suggested one that was uh I
don't know how to read it because it's a
website here that's all I don't know how
to say it here it's w wo spaces here P o
si t SC ience so it's posit science POS
IT science comm and they have these
brain games and I really think in a
number of years that's where I did talk
about this last week that they're
basically instead of having all these
these exercise shows at night that
involved you know getting [ __ ] abs
and all that type of [ __ ] they're
actually going to be selling stuff late
at night that's going to be basically
crunches for your brain and I would
recommend it it's kind of been my new
thing that I do out here I told you I've
been trying to learn learn how to write
with my right hand I'll tell you about
that [ __ ] I'm a lefty and somebody this
comedian was telling me about this book
that he was reading that if you actually
do things with your opposite hand it
opens up different areas of your brain
and so I've been doing that you know I'm
writing with my right hand I've been
throwing [ __ ] around my hotel room with
my left hand I'm kind of [ __ ] up where
I kind of jump
back-and-forth play guitar lefty I play
drums righty I play sports right-handed
I write left-handed I can use tools
either hand [ __ ] rub one out with the
left but in a pinch
okay let's plow ahead so this is the
type of [ __ ] I've been doing so I've
been learning how to write with my right
hand and I basically my hand writing
with my right hand looks it looks like
my handwriting in like fourth grade
looks like if I was in the fourth grade
and I just saw a ghost that's the way it
looks it's looking very spooky but I've
also been trying to learn how to become
a better speller
I just you know something like I always
make fun of how the fact that I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and like Terry Bradshaw I
definitely play up my stupidity but
there's definitely a seed of or maybe
some people would say a deep well of
stupidity that I actually have and most
of it is out of just laziness I mean
there's no reason why I shouldn't know
how to spell the word restaurant at my
age I've been to a bunch of them and
I've tried to spell it a million times
and for the life of me I always forget
if the U comes after the first a or the
second a and I've tried this a number of
times and I'm gonna try to stick with it
as I just as I you know try to type an
email and rather than just hitting
spellcheck and just moving on with my
life I'm trying to actually make a list
of words I don't know how to sell sell
spell see how my brains [ __ ] up and
then what I do is I then I write I write
the word properly like ten times in a
row but I write it with my right hand so
I'm kind of doing two things at once and
it's [ __ ] hilarious because I kind of
left this [ __ ] out and I was just
thinking of the poor cleaning lady
coming in here like one of the words I
was learning how to spell was
Penitentiary so I have penitentiary
written like [ __ ] 12 times in this
spooky
I'm writing with my opposite hand
[ __ ] penmanship and I just kept
thinking of The Shining all work and no
play makes Jack a dull boy you know so
uh I don't know trying to become a
smarter human being
am i boring the [ __ ] out of you because
I think that last segment was a little
boring but I'm into this [ __ ] man I'm
sick of just knowing stuff about sports
I actually you know what I'm going to
Europe in two weeks and and I
desperately do not want to come off as
the typical stupid American at least I'm
in shape okay
so I'm gonna be rude you know
representing us nicely in that category
the fact that I'm 41 years old and I'm
still [ __ ] in shape Jesus Christ I
almost fell backwards on this chair I
didn't understand how far away the
curtains were I should have gone with it
at least it would have been [ __ ]
funny we see if I can lean back here
easy easy easy
it's not working um oh Jesus oh Jesus
hang on one second hello hey let me call
you back in like 20 minutes okay okay
cool all right but um so anyways the
[ __ ] am i talking about I got a I got
this magazine Scientific American
because I'm like I can't keep reading
these [ __ ] sports magazines and dude
there was a guy in there these eggheads
when they want to as much as I love
thrashing people if you notice you know
I just insult the way you look and I say
[ __ ] a lot but these guys are actually
intelligent human beings and this guy
was making fun of people who tells
stories you ever see those stories where
people say they died I was dead for two
minutes and then I came back and then
they come on they start talking about
the stuff that they saw but that the way
this scientist guy breaks the [ __ ] down
scientist guy that I really just say
that the way they do science dude right
the way he breaks it down it's just
[ __ ] brilliant
he basically says you're not dead you
had a near-death experience you were in
aiding a near-death state you weren't
dead if you were dead you're dead they
can't bring you back from being dead all
right even if you [ __ ] heart stops
just because your heart stops the dying
process this guy was the way he broke it
down he said
it can take anywhere from a couple of
minutes to a couple of hours to occur
depending on the conditions so even if
somebody unless you get just [ __ ]
blown up vaporized
even if somebody shoots you in the
[ __ ] heart your brain is still gonna
be firing synapses and whatever the
[ __ ] I'm too stupid I know what it is
but it still takes another couple of
minutes and other stuff like he said can
take up to a couple of hours so these
[ __ ] people who think that dead are
not dead and they're coming on TV
talking about this [ __ ] they saw like
they like they were in another [ __ ] I
don't know universe and they weren't so
he basically in the Deepak Chopra his
front you know is on this Larry King
show describing what's going on so the
guy basically concludes it with this
when because one other scientist was
actually kind of agreeing with Deepak
Chopra by saying you know there's some
stuff out there that we just you know
science you know has no explanation for
and this guy says so what the fact that
we cannot fully explain a mystery
without natural means does not mean it
requires a supernatural explanation it
just means we don't know everything such
uncertainty is at the very heart of
science and is what makes it such a
challenging Enterprise and in that
moment there was a clap of thunder and I
realized that science is religion for
intelligent people this guy isn't saying
that there's no God
but he's also not listening to some guy
half naked dancing around a [ __ ] fire
with a chicken foot you know what I mean
so I think that's what I think I think
science is religion for intelligent
people and I think religion in a lot of
ways is science for morons whenever they
can't explain something they invent
stories of people haven't you know
all-you-can-eat fish coming out of a
wicker basket or [ __ ] you know you
got to have faith you got to have faith
it's a [ __ ] cop out you know if you
went to go buy a [ __ ] car and you go
alright let me know the car wouldn't
start up don't worry don't worry one of
these days that engine's coming back and
it's going to be mad and it's gonna be
judging you
it's ridiculous no gg I don't want to
get off on this [ __ ] ramp but
definitely check it out man if you want
to read some cool stuff
it's called Scientific American and I
don't know kind of on this mission I'm
sick of being a [ __ ] sick of being you
know I'm sick of being [ __ ] stupid I
really am so anyways let's get to uh
let's get to underrated overrated
what are we 38 minutes in look at me I
really can [ __ ] run my mouth when I
want to before I get it too underrated
overrated I got to read this one and I'm
gonna need some help from you guys on
this listen to this one uh this is from
some dude I believe he's in Italy and he
said I kill women's libidos for a living
all right here we go
[ __ ] strap yourselves in for this one
hey Bill um I just got out of my second
of my two long-term relationships three
plus years both of which eerily started
and ended the same both of these girls
were well above average in their sexual
enlightenment when we started dating I'm
not saying they were super freaks but
the kind of girls that have a porno
collection that can rival most guys and
the toys to match also the kind of girls
that while you're home visiting your
parents for the holidays will want to
sneak away from the dinner table and
[ __ ] in the bathroom okay anyways it
seems that the standards for most of
these relations the standard for most
relationship is that you [ __ ] like
rabbits during the first year if you
manage to make it past the one-year mark
there is an exponential decay in the
[ __ ] rationing until you get married or
have kids at which time you're pretty
much done with the sex except for
birthdays and the anniversary however
the sex in these two relationships kept
going strong through the second year at
which point it completely dropped off
and I'm not just and I'm not kidding I'm
talking just done I had to pull out
every trick in the book just to get a
sympathy [ __ ] once every couple of
weeks I'm in a committed relationship
and love these girls I guess you were in
a committed relationship and you love
these girls so I guess you didn't [ __ ]
around all right
and love these girls enough to put up
with the [ __ ] with the idea that
we'll be able to work through the issue
and get back on track however as I
learned once the [ __ ] is boarded up
it's out of business for good
it's like those [ __ ] horrific strip
malls that have been abandoned since the
80s when whatever [ __ ] boom economy in
the area made those [ __ ] people think
they were going to go somewhere so
inevitably when these relationships end
I end up I get red my my [ __ ]
straight a report card on how much I'm
such a great guy and I'm loved so much
and they don't want to lose me as a part
of their lives but they're just not
sexually attracted to me anymore and
that is the [ __ ] and that that and
and this is the best [ __ ] part they
don't know why they don't know why
they're not sexually attracted to me
anymore and really wish they could
change it seriously what the [ __ ] no man
wants to admit to himself let alone an
audience that he's not getting alone
that he's not getting that he's not
getting it done between the sheets
however I can honestly say that I do
alright I'm no [ __ ] Ron Jeremy but I
get the job done I would understand the
plight of these woman if I was fur
blasting them I don't know what that
means what does that mean just jumping
on him like an 18 year old pounding away
or wanting to do the same [ __ ] over and
over again but I usually make a pretty
good damn effort to make sure things
stay fun in the bedroom alright okay
the last two [ __ ] paragraphs let me
just let me just paraphrase this he
basically says that he's like William H
Macy's character in the cooler and he's
saying that he's getting really bitter
and he wants to go out right now and go
meet a woman [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of her
for three months and then give her the
same speech that just happened to him
alright okay first of all don't do that
don't deliberately go out and hurt
somebody because you dated two people
who hurt you that's just it's it's bad
they don't deserve it they didn't hurt
you so don't do that all right I don't
know what to I mean I'd have to have
more details of what the [ __ ] going on
but I will tell you this
from experience I know a lot of people
they get into a relationship with
somebody and that it doesn't go right
they find out that it's not what they're
looking for and then they go out and
then they immediately basically start
dating the same person again
it's not literally the same person but
it's basically you know like just to
make it simple if a woman went out and
was dating met some guy at a [ __ ]
truck stop and he turns out to be an
[ __ ] who's driving a truck [ __ ] a
bunch of other women around the country
she goes I'll never [ __ ] get with a
piece of [ __ ] like that again and where
does she go she goes right back down to
the truck stop which is the same gene
pool of [ __ ] people and I think it's
very interesting that you met two girls
who seemed like they were the exact same
right down to when they wanted to stop
[ __ ] you and I got to admit okay I
guess a woman having a porn collection
is healthy on some level but that you
know I don't know as far as like a girl
you're gonna marry it's like you want
your girl it's that fine line you want
them to [ __ ] your brains out but do you
really want to bang have them want to
[ __ ] you in your parents house I mean I
don't know dude I mean I would I what I
would guess is I would I would start
fishing in a different lake it sounds to
me like you you're [ __ ] goddamn trout
again
okay [ __ ] believe it you know go out
in the ocean you'll catch something else
you know I'm saying
I think you got the same person again I
mean but I mean I would literally have
to [ __ ] be knowing what you're doing
in the bedroom which I don't want to
know well what about you do you start
taking I guess you said you don't taper
off because that's another thing that
happens in relationships you know
there's like you know a big thing with
women is they like kissing and guys are
very focused on the gun on the finish
line the goal so you know you get that
relationship like we haven't had sex in
a while you want to have sex when you
suck it in that [ __ ] thing it you
know and you just start scheduling it uh
how does your day look maybe around 4:00
okay okay we will [ __ ] it for
you know and you're not even
self-conscious so there's no excitement
you just [ __ ] take your clothes off
like you're getting strip-searched on
your way to serving time at [ __ ] some
penitentiary penitentiary PE and ite and
TIAA ry penitentiary
[Laughter]
sorry it's one of the words I learned
this week and I was trying to remember
Rikers Island and I couldn't at that
point so do it I don't know what to tell
you the bottom line I don't give a [ __ ]
who you are how love you are was
somebody after a while you're gonna get
sick of [ __ ] them that's what happens
I don't know I don't know what's going
on I don't know if you have some sort of
like delayed halitosis where for the
first two years you have wonderful
breath and then all of a sudden it's
unbearable I'm just [ __ ] with you I
want to give you a complex but I'm just
saying I don't know what I would try to
meet girls in a different place I would
start with that and I don't know I don't
know do this one is beyond me I've never
I mean part of me wants to say you but
you're being a little too hard on
yourself here but whatever go out there
and you know go bang some [ __ ] women
you're single go out there bang some
[ __ ] women and as always always talk
to women that you think are out of your
league always do that [ __ ] the worst
thing they can do is say no but one of
them is gonna [ __ ] say yes that'll
give you more confidence and you'll keep
moving up the draft board next thing you
know you're pulling [ __ ] out of the
first round rather than drafting like
you [ __ ] won the Super Bowl last year
you know having that 28th pick praying
that the female version of [ __ ] Dan
Marino's still around that didn't make
sense but you know what I'm saying
anyways am I almost done here 46 minutes
in 46 minutes into the podcast let's
wrap this [ __ ] up here people with a
little bit of underrated overrated shall
we
underrated bill last week you got an
email from a fan that recounted his
sister's Wiccan wedding personally I
think the ritual was that was discussed
in the wedding is [ __ ] mind-numbing ly
insane but part of me has to give it up
to the couple that got married
oh sorry underrated as having balls
they knew their ritual wood would not be
well-received but they did not give a
[ __ ] it was their day and they had the
conviction to do what they wanted even
knowing that their family and guests
would not warmly receive the whole
gibberish chanting and bloodletting okay
so there you go having the balls to have
[ __ ] annoy everyone in your family
another quick thing here some people are
travelling to Boston they know that I
grew up there and I also [ __ ] travel
around the country and this guy said hey
Bill I'm going there with my wife she
used to she um she used to live there
but I would also you know so she knows
where to go I'd like to know you know
have you tell me where to [ __ ] to go I'm
paraphrasing obviously I haven't lived
there since 1995 dude so I'm I'm gonna
try to tell you to go to some of my
favorite places from back in the day I
would start go to capys liquors on route
1 in Saugus right before you know get a
good six-pack in you may be some
Michelob and then go up to the go up to
the kowloon get some [ __ ] Chinese
food and of course another great liquor
store out in the Boston area is out in
Brockton Massachusetts go to Blanchard's
liquor store out by the Westgate Mall
you might want to check if that's still
there but I know the bowling alley is
that's a great place you know go out
there and now put on some flock of
seagulls and try to talk to some chick
with way too much who drew a triangle of
pink on both of her cheeks I'm just
[ __ ] with you the penalty box go to a
Bruins game go stop by the penalty box
that's a good bar it's really alcohol
base stay away from the Freedom Trail
okay stay away from the freedom trail I
don't know about you guys but there's
nothing more boring to me anyways than
the Revolutionary War it is mine
lovingly boring with the old weaponry
it's like you know it's like the
original Atari after you saw this
PlayStation [ __ ] we've been doing for
the last you know 50 years so oh you
hear that [ __ ] did she sing it again
wait a second wait for it
not a [ __ ] guy in the violin can you
hear it you probably can't [ __ ] hear
all right um oh and somebody sent me
something and that's the last thing I'll
tell you guys before I'll tell you all
they have a good [ __ ] week as I
always do trying to add on a nice
positive note hey let me hit refresh
here just to see who won this foods won
in this [ __ ] game come on
refresh Jesus Christ
he isn't unbelievable how quickly your
[ __ ] computer gets old it's like cool
for the first [ __ ] week and then you
download a couple things and then it's
like you know it's like Brad Pitt at the
beginning of that movie where he played
the old baby anybody see that movie I
don't think I've ever laughed so [ __ ]
hard in my life when that guy came in
and he was trying to get some [ __ ] in
he hears her and he looks down there was
that little old baby
you want talk about killing a [ __ ]
woman's a guy's libido the [ __ ] is going
on with my computer I didn't have the
thing I actually have dial-up right now
if you can believe it that's probably
another one of the problems all right
here we go come on come on oh you
[ __ ] [ __ ] two to one Pittsburgh 804
left I like it though I forget the name
of the guy but we have a new defenseman
maybe that'll help us to make up for the
fact that we don't have phil kessel
anymore even though for some reason a
lot of people don't like him so anyways
this guy setting this last thing I'll
read you guys this guy sent me something
about you know I was talking about when
you're going to go buy things and people
asked for your phone number and all this
[ __ ] information and it [ __ ]
creeps me out every time they do that I
just think that they should play in the
beginning of that iron main song the
prisoner you remember that from the 80s
you remember how that thing went
[Music]
remember this the new number two who's
number one you are number six most
psycho laugh ever can you imagine if
your [ __ ] dad would laugh at you like
that back in the day be like son how
many beers did you have tonight you're
just like I just had two all right he
just [ __ ] dulles and the lights start
dim and it's gonna be over so anyways
this [ __ ] guy did that make any sense
by the way I don't know I'm [ __ ]
sitting with one microphone no
headphones in a [ __ ] hotel room this
is what you get all right so this guy
said bill can you believe how much
[ __ ] information people are willing to
give away for know to strangers for no
reason because I got my hair cut the
other day and the first thing they say
to me before hello or what can I do for
you is the first thing out of the gate
is what's your phone number so I say why
do you need my phone number she says so
we know who you are when you come in
which is [ __ ] because they don't
know you when you come in they still
have to ask what your goddamn number is
see you gotta love someone who actually
[ __ ] uses their brain so anyway she
goes he says I don't want to give you my
number so then she scoffs in his face
and says um we don't send the
information out to anyone it's just to
keep track of you here that's it um and
then she says then okay then the guy
says the guy written wrote this really
badly here so then I guess he responds
to that doesn't make me feel any better
you don't need my phone number to cut my
hair then this slag does this fine
whatever that sounded exactly like your
exaggerated impression of a dumb broad
then she goes how about your address
dude this is [ __ ] them you know what
all these corporations are sharing this
information to figure out exactly what
you buy when you buy it what you like
the best so they can just [ __ ] I
don't know what
you know jack the prices of this [ __ ] up
so anyways um she goes how about your
address and the guy goes what are you
gonna do drop the haircut off at my
house just cut my [ __ ] now there's
three people in line behind me in this
worthless tub of [ __ ] Jesus leans around
me and says and says that I guess to the
people behind him sorry this takes
longer when they then he writes they you
know don't give any information and then
he says sarcastically oh I see I'm the
one compliment complicating this
transaction and it's not even her fault
it's her okay oh and it's not even her
fault it's her corporate creep bosses
and all the [ __ ] sheep that let
people do whatever they want sorry this
is so long well you should apologize to
my listeners because they had to listen
to me read it yeah man don't give those
people your [ __ ] phone numbers don't
give him your address I do that can we
get your phone number I know you can't
we're not gonna do anything with it
that's fine that's fine I know you're
not gonna do anything with it I don't
want you to have my phone number we need
to call me up and see how my [ __ ]
haircuts going
is it still short and you think you need
an adjustment did I tell you that story
but when I went into CVS and that guy
who looked with the pee-wee Herman
haircut there was two foreigners in
front of me they barely spoke English
and they he asked if they wanted one of
those save e save cards and they said no
and he goes that's all right I'll just
scan one anyways and he scans it so I
walk up and I'm ready for this guy he
goes do you have our little save e save
card and I say no I don't and he goes
well just scan it anyways and I go no I
don't want you do and then he scanned it
and I said I said excuse me
what did I just say to you I just said I
don't want that and you scanned it
anyways why did you just do that and he
goes it's alright I'll on scan it all on
scan it and I go what do you get like
half a cent for every person that you
get you know that that you get on the
[ __ ] list there and he goes no I
don't it's like really is that way he
can't make eye contact with me you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] he probably didn't
even unscanned the goddamn thing you
know I don't understand people to help
out corporations I just don't have they
done anything to demonstrate that they
give a flying [ __ ] about you or the
drinking water in your town don't help
those [ __ ]
I mean you can if you want to but that's
just I would just I think it would be a
better world if these [ __ ] pricks did
no every goddamn thing about you you
know pretty soon you're gonna walk in
there and they're gonna [ __ ] asked if
you can put a do they can just bug you
like gene Hackman and the conversation
right all right do it I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about you know what
I'm gonna go down Melissa this lady
singer songs so I don't have to think
there's a nice little crowd down there
there's got to be at least 26 people
down there which I think in downtown San
Jose actually constitutes a mob maybe
somebody'll get tased and shot in the
abdomen I don't know what all right
that's the podcast for this week thank
you guys so much for listening I am
currently revamping my website and I
hope that everything's going to be up to
speed I recently went over 10,000 people
on my mailing list so I'm really excited
about that and if you want to know
what's going on you know especially like
if you see you know when I switched over
to Lipson with the podcast and all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you were out of the loop
it's because you weren't on my mailing
list I'm not sure how funny is this how
funny is this
how [ __ ] hypocritical am i I just
said don't give you phone number out to
these [ __ ] and now here I am asking for
your web address I
all right
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
if your
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
you